[Music]
blake was talking to me and i all of a
sudden i like everything he said just
went away and i had to grab his arm and
i was like something is wrong kelly
clarkson revealing a second health scare
that took place just one week after her
appendix burst in May if you'll remember
each he broke the news that Kelly had
her appendix removed one day after she
hosted the 2019 Billboard Music Awards
well now she tells People mag that
surgery assist burst on her ovary while
she was filming live shows for the voice
that was more painful than the
appendicitis no it was just that
literally it was like two weeks in my
life where just physically like things
were just like a domino effect it was
really funny well I don't know if I'd
say that's funny but I'm glad she's
being a good sport about it and this is
also one of the reasons why we love
Kelly so much
she's always open about what's going on
with her when it comes to her body you
recently opened up about your 37 pound
oh wait lotta plant there yeah well it's
basically about Reed you know kind of
rethinking everything how we you know
don't how we eat processed foods how we
spray our foods how we treat antibiotics
like it's tic tacs you know all of it so
it's it's really it's a really great
book that changed my life but I'm not
saying it will change yours
so whatever and good news Kelly assures
fans that all is well with her she says
she's great now and that's good to know
because the American Idol alum has a lot
on her plate right now
The Voice returns on September 23rd and
Kelly's new talk show will premiere on
September 9th I'm like really excited
about I'm slightly terrified the people
have that much confidence
I'm like God I let people down but I
don't know I'm I'm pretty stoked about
it
we've this whole tour that I just
finished up we did this whole live part
during it and I did I interviewed people
here and there and I'm been working on
my listening skills cannot wait for
Kelly's new show to debut and glad to
hear that she's doing all right for all
the latest on Kelly and your other
favorite celebs keep it locked to all
things et until next time I'm Katie
Krauss and
for now
you